Imagine Alice has an idea
and she wants to share it.
There are so many ways to share an idea.
She could draw a picture,
make an engraving,
write a song.
(piano playing)
(pounding)
send a telegraph,
(wire clicking)
or an email.
But how are these things different?
And more importantly,
why are they the same?
This story is about the
fundamental particle
of all forms of communication.
It begins with a special skill
you likely take for granted,
language.
All language allows you to
take thought or mental object
and break it down into a
series of conceptual chunks.
These chunks are externalized
using a series signals or symbols.
Humans express themselves
using a variation
in sound and physical action.
As do chirping birds and dancing bees,
and man-made machines
exchanging a dancing stream
of electrical vibrations.
Even our bodies are built
according to instructions
stored inside microscopic
books known as DNA.
All are different forms of one thing:
Information.
In simplest terms,
information is what allows
one mind to influence another.
It's based on the idea of
communication as selection.
Information, no matter the form,
can be measured using a fundamental unit.
In the same way we can measure
the mass of different objects
using a standard measure
such as kilograms or pounds,
this allows us to precisely
measure and compare
the weight of say rocks, water, or wheat,
using a scale.
Information, too, can
be measured and compared
using a measurement called entropy.
Think of it as an information scale.
We intuitively know that a single page
from some unknown book
has less information
than the entire book.
We can describe exactly how much
using a unit called the bit.
A measure of surprise.
So no matter how Alice wants
to communicate a specific message,
hieroglyphics,
music,
computer code,
each would contain the
same number of bits,
though in different densities,
and a bit is linked to a very simple idea.
The answer to a yes or no question.
Think of it as the language of coins.
So how is information actually measured?
Does information have a speed limit?
A maximum density?
Information theory hold
the exciting answer
to these questions.
It's an idea over 3,000
years in the making,
but before we can understand this,
we must step back and explore, perhaps,
the most powerful
invention in human history.
The alphabet.
And for this, we return to the cave.